Syrian Kurds here, in Qamishli, northeastern
Syria are angry.
In December, Donald Trump surprised everyone
by annonucing that the US would pull out of
Syria - and quickly.
That could leave the Kurds vulnerable to attacks
from Turkey which sees some of them as terrorists.
The Kurds have been fighting tooth and nail
against Islamic State alongside US troops.
its been a costly fight.
The Kurds fear being abandoned by a US withdrawal
and so too do many of the US's allies in the
region.
Enter John Bolton...
US National Security Advisor.
He's jetting around the Middle East clarifying
confusion, putting out the fire that Trump
started.
His message: the US isn't simply packing up
and leaving.
In December, Trump told the Pentagon to prepare
to leave Syria within a 100 days.
Now, he's changed his mind:
We are pulling back in Syria.
We`re going to be removing our troops.
I never said we`re doing it that quickly
Bolton, recently in Israel, also says that
the US's withdrawal is conditional.
We're gonna to be discussing the president's
decision to withdraw but to do so from northeast
Syria in a way that makes sure that ISIS (Islamic
State group) is defeated and is not able to
revive itself
He's in Ankara to assure Turkey that the US
WILL leave... but bit by bit.
That chimes with Reccep Tayyip Erdogan, Turkey's
President.
Turkey sees itself as the dominant regional
power writing in the New York Times this week,
he said he agreed
that the US SHOULD withdraw... but, slowly.
Bolton has a big challenge in Ankara: his
OTHER condition for a
US withdrawal is
that
Turkey PROMISES not to attack
the US's allies, the Kurds.
For Turkey, which has a long-standing and
bloody fued with
the Kurds, that
will
be hard
to swallow.